Marv Albert joining us here once again
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Marv
direct how you doin it was certainly the
unexpected last night well I mean did
you see anything pregame anything coming
out of a locker room maybe a half body
language anything that gave an
indication something like this might be
on the way you know people always try to
measure the watch warmups whatever the
sport and try to get some kind of
indication but it's so rare that you
really can actually see anything and
always so the Celtics walked in kind of
with that you know the heads hanging
whole Brad Stevens is always up you know
we chatted with him before the game and
you know told us what basically he was
going to tell the players etc but to see
a game like that where particularly with
LeBron having his worst playoff game
perhaps ever I know he's had even low in
numbers it was a seven point game while
with Miami in the playoffs that was his
playoff career low but he just didn't
semen engaged I know at the start and we
saw with Kyrie Irving in Game two
where in Game one I should say where
everyone else was into it
and Kevin Love was on fire and Irving
was playing well so he kind of laid back
but I kept thinking that when it got
close to the fourth quarter last night
that okay now LeBron is going to start
it and you know ride for the bucket and
start throwing up threes but he just
never got into it I think it's just hard
to even for a guy like the Bron to just
turn it on well I mean and and it can't
be that he's you know tired because I
mean the amount of rest that this team
has had in the playoffs and and
certainly games one and two certainly
looked like the rust had been knocked
off of it existed at all what did you
see that the Celtics did maybe you just
tip your cap to something that Brad
Stevens and the rest of that team did
defensively games went to no question
don't use the word great you know
lightly I mean he you know obviously did
a butler and he's done a wonderful job
with Boston but I thought I said it on
the telecast of course the Celtics would
have preferred had Isiah Thomas been
available but I thought without Thomas
on the floor aside from the fact that
the Celtic defense was better I thought
that the Cavs who were trapping and
double teaming and the new basketball
were blitzing you know really made it
difficult for Thomas and I thought
without that energy on the part of
Cleveland uh I thought the sense of
urgency wasn't the same you know they
were flying all over the court against
Isiah and now you had a normal line up
because Isaiah Thomas won not hurt is a
brilliant player I mean he was you know
had interest and I had an incredible
year but with his size I know he's
listed at 585 9 I think maybe he's 5 7
you know I mean he is really small and
it changes the game sometimes in the
Cavaliers case it changed the game to
their benefit you know Terron lue who
had been saying all during the course of
that last the last couple of weeks where
the Cavaliers were struggling that
you'll see our defense will turn on on
the playoffs and as it turns out it did
although III thought that actually the
Cavaliers who were so poor defensively
in the last month and a half actually
emerged in the playoffs at the defensive
end oboe they had people forget they had
you know that first series against
Indiana was not easy and they were CJ
Miles jump shot away again one losing to
the Pacers so uh they got better
you know they evolved as the series
continued on but I thought they just
didn't have the same kind of activity
LeBron was for whatever reason was not I
don't know if it was ill you know people
are saying that after the game because
it's so unusual to see him not play at a
high level Marvin
who's calling the Eastern Conference
Finals and we'll have Game four tomorrow
beginning at 8:00 Eastern on TNT and now
a game 5 from Boston joining me here
from Cleveland on the Rich Eisen show on
the conversation out of Boston already
is is how expendable is Isiah Thomas now
that there's a first overall selection
well which the Celtics can use to
perhaps get Thomas's replacement there's
a 9 figure decision coming for the
Celtics involving is is is uh his deal
that's coming whether it's max or not
how much was last night do you think
sustainable mark well I I this is a team
I think what we're looking at right now
will not be a roster that we see opening
day next season so I think there are so
many possibilities because Danny Ainge
the vice-president of operations has a
lot of possibilities with that number
one pick which you can either take or
they could trade and they have I think
that it's a very strong roster there are
pieces that you can you can move and I
think he did they have a decision on
Isaiah Thomas because as you mentioned
the kind of money that he would
eventually be looking for he has another
year but I could see where they might go
in another direction
not because of what happened last night
but I think just in terms of how they
want to play the game and have a more
perhaps a more conventional point guard
whether it's work Folsom ball whatever
but you know I mean the chance they're
taking is they're breaking up what has
been a very good team a team that
centers first in the east but you know
they're not good enough to win the
championship I mean with this current
lineup so I think and I think Danny
realizes that this is not not the year I
mean I think he'd do that even as they
were playing so well during the regular
season but I could see where he may go
you know for the bonanza and make some
moves so they could be in position next
year in the year after
so I'm having Marv Albert here on the
Rich Eisen show can you compare what you
saw from Friday to Sunday
in anything that you've called an
interval
Friday was one of the most unusual games
I've never seen anything like that even
even going back to some of the Nick
teams that I broadcast you know like
late 70s and early 80s and even you know
fairly recent times but to see a blowout
like that where team is down by 50
points at one stretch and lose by 44 and
even when the subs came on to Cleveland
and they were playing hard I mean they
they maintained the 40 point lead you
just don't you know you don't see scores
like that it was it was just incredible
as embarrassing as avery bradley said
after the game i there was nothing that
you would see in game 2 that would lead
to what took place last night I you know
it's very easy to say well they you know
Cleveland didn't play as hard but they
did I mean they you know they had a
terrific first half but I think they
shot when you fall in love with the
three I mean they shot so well in the
first half particularly Kevin Love from
downtown and then you know to first
something like two for 17 in the second
half I mean it shortcuts the game if
you're hitting shots but I just they
attempted 40 and all I just don't think
you can do that on a on a regular basis
because you're not going to continue
unless maybe you're the Golden State
Warriors you know where you really have
even though Cleveland and Boston both
shoot the three well but you don't have
spectacular three-point shooters as the
Warriors do and then there's a sense
Marv that the NBA needed a game like
yesterday because you've got the Western
Conference Finals you know we all know
that there's no Kewanee no Tony Parker
and then one would think no chance and
and in a league where the entire
offseason and then the regular season
was filled up with well who in the world
is going to try and prevent the Cavs
with the now Durant joined warriors
super team from materializing in the NBA
Finals and and to see just even once
just one drawing of blood yeah when it's
least expected needed a compelling game
I mean I thought Game seven
between Washington and Boston was was
really good but there have not been it's
been a lot of blow out just happened
before I think it's cyclical you know
and could happen again but yeah they've
been shorter series uh many routes so it
was nice to see a game like that and as
you mentioned I think Old State San
Antonio because the loss of of Kauai and
others and that's you know that's over
us and ending you can have a pretty long
stretch between the end of the
Conference Finals and then the NBA
Finals which you know it's not like the
NFL we you know he can play you know
every week and have all that time in
between but this is too much time for
basketball and in terms of you hearing
the echo chamber of what people are
saying
Marv are you on Twitter at all does
anybody show you what's being said on
Twitter if you're not there do you do
use it once in a while I find out I know
I'm not on Twitter okay not York you
don't have like a secret account my kids
tell me no do they get my kids fill me
in every once in a while they insist I
should be on Instagram but I'm on Reggie
Miller's Instagram okay so often I feel
it's enough because I know cost us and
I'll sometimes talk about what they see
but I don't think they're on it either I
don't think I wrote out I can tell you
for sure you can tell now but you don't
have a flip phone like Bob right no you
don't no no no I I am mister techy
compared to Bob at out I mean my iPad is
essential okay and of course the iPhone
and I do have various interesting apps
where I have we have two pugs so we have
talking pugs on that you know important
things like that in my life
what are your pugs names tell me tell me
their cat ricean Madison what are they
Trixie and Madison Trixie and Missouri
nice with us is there any is there any
question good talk you know you see so
many movies about talking and talking
that's but I always wonder what would
they be saying what would their voice
sound like okay
so I just was wondering you know what
what the significance of the dogs I
thought maybe
kristaps would be in one pug yeah that'd
be good one you know I don't know we are
we do funnel at the end basketball very
cool and Madison is that for the garden
is that at least we got that no no it's
just names that my wife has come up with
after a great extensive study that's
that's basically yes but you should get
the D the animal talking app okay
recommended I have nothing to do with it
okay it you know if you want to
entertain other people particularly you
know it's very good if you want to annoy
anybody that's fantastic
Marv appreciate the time we'll chat down
the line I love listening to you and and
you know I don't care sharing this stuff
I my kids are watching now they're eight
and six and I'm like when I was there
your age I was listening to this man and
I'm a sportscaster because of it and it
felt like you very much I was 12 at that
time I know it started it's remarkable
how early you did your career I don't
mean to date anything but you know I
it's a it's a treasure that I'm able to
share that with my kids so appreciate
your call right you got it you got it
tomorrow valor
you're on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint